Thanks for taking a moment and responding. Now there are several ways that this
disorder can potentially impair a person's life, so let's take a look at this
in more detail. First we see that people with schizophrenia experience a
decline in their overall level of functioning. This means that it can be
difficult for a person to work at a job that requires a level of skill and
concentration that they may have had prior to the onset of the disorder. In
devastating cases, the person loses the ability to be a working individual.
Moreover, demands such as raising the children, taking care of the house, or
meeting societal demands becomes overwhelming, such that the person is not able
to function appropriately.